لن تخبر مدبريه الانقلاب متى واين سنضرب
هذا قرار عملي سيتخذه رؤساء الدول
تم وقطعي بالنسبه للتدخل العسكري باش
يفهموا قطعا ان الجزائر لن تستعمل القوه
مع جيرانها ابدا مهما كانت الظروف
[موسيقى]
كان اعتقد بان سيكون هناك تحضيرات عسكريه
جديه
وتظهر بشكل يوحي بان التدخل احتمال التدخل
يبقى دائما قائما في الوقت الذي ينبغي ان
يكون فيه مفاوضات موازيه لها
[موسيقى]
يدين المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن والحكومه
الانتقاليه الحمله المضلله التي تخدم
مصلحه شخص واحد وتخدم مجامعته الهدف من
الحمله هو تقويض الثقه في سلطات
الانتقاليه وافشال جميع مسائل حل التفاوضي
للخروج من الازمه لتبرير تدخل عسكري او
كلا رؤساء بعض الدول تنفيذه الى قوه دوليه
باسم اقواس
[موسيقى]
لن تتدخل تشاد عسكريه لكثير من الاسباب
نفضل دائما ان يتحاوروا بينهم ولن نتدخل
عسكريا ابدا نفضل الحوار وان يعود
الاستقرار الى النيجر ان القرار فيما
يتعلق كيف تحكم النيجر نفسها هو فقط
مسؤوليه الشعب النيجيري ولا غيرهم